welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to Avengers endgame has just had
its world premiere and after a week of
big leaks
we finally have a full comprehensive
breakdown of the film and its storyline
if you like me and can't help yourself
and want to know what happens and you've
come to the right place or the wrong one
depending on how you look at it
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down the main plot points of the story
as provided by dr. Faust from reddit who
has apparently seen the film and even
provided screenshots and video from the
premiere this is of course full spoilers
ahead and whilst the plot won't be 100%
verified until we see the movie for
ourselves it seems pretty likely this is
from reddit though so take it with a
pinch of salt as always this is your
last last last chance to back out but if
you're still here
thanks for clicking the video I hope you
enjoy it now let's get into the full
plot breakdown of Avengers and games
Avengers and game opens with Hawkeye
training his daughter with a bow and
arrow before his family are all
mercilessly taken out by the snap we
then cut to Tony and nebula adrift in
space with the former recording his
message to pepper
Tony falls asleep and awakens to see
Captain Marvel outside of the ship who
helps them return to Earth which is
where they meet up with the rest of the
survivors the film then follows them
attempting to track down Stannis whose
location is given away by nebula because
she knows of a God now he said he would
retire - upon completing his final goal
they arrived there to find Thanos alone
and he informs them that used the
gauntlet to destroy the stones he is
weak and Thor goes for the head this
time killing him in the process snap
forward 5 years and Captain Marvel
states that she must go to another
planet and will be back for a while
cut to Louise's ban which is inside a
storage unit and after a rat crawls over
the quantum controls Scott is freed we
follow him as he walks the streets
confused as to why everything looks like
it's from 28 days later before he
arrives at a memorial with all of the
names of the missing on a large stone he
then travels to the Avengers facility
where he tells Nancy
about the quantum realm and how he could
build a time machine they visit Tony to
ask for help but he turns them down as
he's happy with his life
Bruce's also become Professor Hulk and
he helps the Avengers build a machine to
find the stones in the past
unfortunately the machine is faulty so
Scott can't go back which is when Tony
returns giving Kappa shield back and
staying that he will help Tony fixes up
the machine
but before recruiting anyone else they
wish to test it out themselves to make
sure that it definitely works this
smaller group travels to a specific
moment in Avengers history namely the
Battle of New York Hulk goes to meet the
ancient one who refuses to give him the
time stone but then does when she learns
that Doctor Strange will give it to
Thanos cap Iron Man and ant-man attempt
again the tesseract from Loki but Hydra
forces including crossbones managed to
get it instead cap meets crossbones and
manages to convince him to hand over the
briefcase when he utters the words hail
Hydra on his way out present cap
accidentally meets his 2012 self who
believes that he is Loki and they battle
it out president Kaplan tells him that
he knows Bucky is alive which causes the
past one to believe him
from here they return and recruit the
rest of the Avengers Thor and rocket go
to Asgard to get the reality stone but
Thor is a complete wreck at this point
and has become fair after taking the
snap badly he sees Freya and follows her
while rocket goes after the stone Brea
tells him to pull himself together
before rocket runs in being chased by
gods and the two returned to the present
during this Thor also grabbed his hammer
so he has it in the present and this
kind of plays into the later part of the
movie war machine and nebula gautama
rock
unbeknownst to nebula her past self is
hooked up with databanks on Thanos's
ship and the villain looms where all the
stones are as well as what happens to
him together they knock out quill during
his dance in the intro of guardians of
the galaxy and get the Power Stone the
two try to teleport back but only war
machine makes a and pass a nebula shows
up and fights the present one
she bests her and then takes a place in
the present Matt and Hawkeye go to
Boromir where they meet Red Skull and I
told how to retrieve the stone the to
fight and Quinn tries to jump off the
cliff but NAT grabs him and sacrifices
itself so that they can get the stone
flashback to the present and everyone is
devastated by Black Widows death Tony
and Bruce
the Infinity Gauntlet which Hulk wields
he snaps his fingers and restores all
the past life lost which is confirmed by
Hawkeye's wife who calls him past nebula
activates the quantum teleporter and
summons Stannis's ship which destroys
Avengers HQ cap Thor and Tony team up
against an ass but Thanos beats Thor and
is about to kill him which is when cap
lifts Thor's hammer and beats him with
it
then our summons his entire army
including the Black Order it looks like
cap is gonna be all along which is when
he is Sam's voice and pretty much
everyone returns and they charge him
during this Hawkeye has managed to get
the Infinity Gauntlet which gets passed
about as a sort of MacGuffin with
everyone trying to get it eventually
Captain Marvel arrives destroys Thanos
his ship and takes it but Thanos
wrestles it off her which is when Tony
picks it up and puts it on Tony snaps
his fingers wiping out all of Thanos his
forces and Thanos himself now prepare to
hold back those tears guys because due
to the force of the gauntlet Tony is
killed and he dies in peppers arms after
saving the day and his funeral a
holographic Tony gives a message to
everyone including his daughter Thor
designates Valkyrie as the Queen of
Asgard and he joins the guardians of the
galaxy with him and quell fighting out
over who she be captain of the ship
cap goes on a mission to return the
stones back to their proper places and
Hulk says that should be back in five
seconds but he doesn't return outside
salmon Bucky seen old man sat at a bench
and they realize it's cap Steve has a
wedding ring on and he passes the shield
to Sam who is honored to take up the
mantle we then cut to a young Captain
America dancing with Peggy Carter at the
house which is when the credits roll and
on to the post-credits scene now
apparently the post-credits scene isn't
so much is seen as it is all of the cast
of bowing to the audience before a piece
of paper with all of their signatures on
appears this is actually a pretty
amazing way to end the movie I think and
if that's correct I really hope that
it's the way that it closes out this
huge chapter of the MCU obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on this leak
and if you think it's legitimate or not
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my breakdown
for the 5 minutes of leaked footage that
we got on the film which will be linked
at the
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like it subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]